it's time for season five of Stargate
command our fan fiction our explanation
in video to Amazon on how damn easy
bringing Stargate back would be
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
so if you are following the channel
you'll know that I've been doing these
videos these SGC videos explaining to
Amazon how easy it would be to bring
back Stargate we have the SGC at the
core and then a bunch of series that
hang off it we're already up to season
five we've done season one The SGC
Series where we hopefully catch up a
little bit we find out a little bit
about what's going on in the Galaxy 12
years on from SGU ending and we get to
see the new Stargate command we find out
there's a new civilian leader we find
out the world knows about the Stargate
and so on and so on in series two we
find out what's going on with the
Atlantis in season three we went off and
saved Eli
and this
is my favorite room in the whole ship
this is the Stargate room
look at that
isn't it something
Rush figures at this gate predates all
the others we know of like a prototype
it's the only way we're ever going to
get home
in season four we got the Ancients
prequel but throughout these four
seasons so far we've known about the
evil furlings now I know what you're
gonna say evil Ewoks who doesn't want to
see that
but in this season in season five we're
going to see a little bit more about
what's going on in The Wider Universe in
the first season of SGC we've got to
learn about what's going on on Earth
throughout the rest of the seasons we
would have had hints about what was
going on elsewhere but in this season I
really want to bring it home and I
really want to find out
intergalactically what the political and
Military situation is now I don't really
want to have one season or one big
episode where we just catch up with
everything that's gone on the 12 years
since stargate's been off what I want to
do is ask questions answer them have
hints and stuff that intertwine through
all of the seasons but in this season I
really want to find out what's gone on
and what the military situation is like
I say where are the alliances where are
the enemies I want to hint that there's
been a conflict with illusion Alliance
something that we might come back to I
want to hear that there's an alliance
with the Jefferson book that that's had
problems and that is something else that
again later on we could flash back to I
also want to see the toll and and how
the alliance there that I've already
hinted at in other episodes
now there aren't many toll and left but
they were so technologically advanced
there would be a massive asset in this
new Human Alliance so this spreading
everyone wants to stars now this season
would actually have sort of a
two-pronged thing to it I want to see an
SG team going through the gate
and that's I think how the series would
start they go through the gate because
we've had a message from the remaining
tokra not that there would be many of
those left either and that there was an
unusual energy signature on this distant
planets a few months before around the
time of the first series when we got to
see the furlings appear for the first
time
so an SG team goes to investigate and
what they find is a Stargate that is
unusual it is hooked up to a massive
power supply it doesn't look like a
normal gate it's very strange now we
will know from the prequel series series
four that this is actually where the
furling the banished were imprisoned but
the SGC are finding that for the first
time so they start the science and they
start trying to figure out what's gone
on they can detect a residual radiation
there are lots of markings on the walls
there are lots of warnings about not
playing with the Stargate and there is a
history of why the furlings were
imprisoned
so finally we actually in the SGC in the
Towery know what's going on and that
this unusual new enemy really is the
furnace and they really are a threat
in the series though that would then cut
and split between another big event a
launching of the BC 306
now in a previous video Matt shut up
Matt he did a video talking about what
he envisaged the BC 306 to look like he
called his vessel the Phoenix he said he
would have a wormhole drive and be very
exotic now my plan is a little bit more
restrained I think the bc306 would just
be a more conventional evolution of what
we've seen already the BC 304 a bigger
BC 305 which I can't wait to see in the
new series as well and then this new BC
306 now there's lots of fan arts and
stuff that I think is great I'll show a
couple here and something like this I
think would be fantastic
it would have obviously more advanced
technology in the same way that the BC
304 the deadless was a complete
Revolution compared to the Prometheus I
want to see the same again this should
be a vessel that can take on anything in
the Galaxy I want to see some more
curved shapes to the design I want it to
be a little less boxy one than what
we've seen before and obviously
significantly bigger this really should
be a vessel that could go into battle
alongside an Asgardian warship and not
look out of place now while the BC 306 I
would like to call it the Prometheus a
but that's just me getting the comments
tell me what you would call it
is on its space trials it comes across
an unusual vessel a ship they've never
seen before
they scan it they can tell that it's
quite a powerful vessel so they
investigate
there is an immediate attack the
Prometheus a is damaged but has
obviously the best Shields the best
weapons and a fight ensues I would love
to see this fight really like I want you
know I want to see one of the Great
Space Battles in sci-fi now I want it to
be over two or three episodes I want
them to be fight hiding in the nebula
doing repairs but I want strategy I want
them to be fighting the distance then
coming close again I want them to never
really know what the enemy is at first
and they're influenced to be running
away from it and then them to have a
counter-attack you know I really want to
see like a chess game played out now by
the end of that battle the obviously the
Prometheus has to survive heavily
damaged it makes its way back or the
other vessel leaves and escapes I'd like
to see the Prometheus almost at an ends
there it can take out the enemy vessel
it's got to be a one kill but it pulls
back giving the furlings hint there a
chance to escape they realize through
the battle that this vessel has ancient
technology or at least technology that
looks like ancient technology to them
they also detect zpms now we know from
again the Atlantis series that the
furlings got their hands on some zpms so
when the Prometheus returns to the SGC
they have a big conversation
and they realize that this enemy was
probably the first engagement with the
furlings and the deferlings have already
begun constructing news warships
so now we have to ask the question what
are the furlings actually intending to
do now we know from the previous series
that the furlings created the Gold World
there was supposed to be a race to look
after Humanity as all the other great
races began to leave or Ascend but
they've banished turned them into the
gold we got to know because this sect of
the feelings believed that actually we
didn't need a teacher we needed a master
we needed somebody to watch over us and
to control our numbers or we would
become a cancer that spread throughout
the Galaxy
so
the other species disagreed they saw the
best in us and wanted us to grow and
develop and join them as one of the
great races so they banished this sect
of the feelings
but what does the banished now want what
do they want from us they're obviously
not here to look after us they're not
here to help us
but what is their end game
but we're gonna find out that in a later
season that's not for now I'm not going
to say to you now that I would love this
to be like 10 12 episodes per season and
I'd love to see two or three seasons a
year so by this point we would be two or
three years into the new Stargate series
now I've said to you before I actually
think when they bring back a Stargate
series they should do a sort of Marvel
style in phases and this would be coming
up to the end of phase one
so season six would be that finale it
would be the first Avengers movie of the
new Stargate series could it even be a
movie I really want you guys there to
get into the comments and tell me what
you want season six to look like or the
movie the follow season five to look
like
is there going to be a big conflict with
furlings and what do the furlings really
want this is an interactive process here
I do read the comments I do take your
comments on board so
get your imaginations flowing get
writing tell me what you think should
happen
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
as always if you enjoy the content and
you want to support the channel hit the
join button and become a fully fledged
side tracker as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
foreign